&gt;&gt; So you've now seen these two equations that look pretty similar to one
another several times. We have y equals Ax squared plus Bx plus C. And we have 0
equals Ax squared plus Bx plus C. What I want to do with this quiz is make sure
that we understand the difference between the two of these equations. When do we
use each one, and what purpose do they each serve? So I've given you some
different options over here, four different options. And each one of these
describes either this equation or this equation. So for each of these four
things, please pick the equation that it describes. Which one of these graphs a
parabola? Which one finds the x-coordinates of the x-intercepts of a parabola?
Which one relates y to x? And which one can be solved? Please pick the equation
for each that best fits this description.